for America to bind the wounds of  division president-elect Donald Trump  meets with president barack obama the  two men in the oval office at the white  house Thursday morning Trump called  Obama a quote very good man saying it  was an honor to meet with him it is no  secret that the president-elect and I  have some pretty significant differences  but remember eight years ago President  Bush and I had some pretty significant  differences but president bush's team  could not have been more professional or  more gracious in making sure we had a  smooth transition so that we could hit  the ground running Trump added that he  plans to seek counsel from Obama and  that this first meeting is one of many  to come we are now all rooting for  success in uniting and leading the  country working together we will begin  the urgent task of rebuilding our nation  and renewing the American dream  you